if you think about a robot you usually
think about the complete humanoid made
of metal and this is very good if you
want to do repeated tasks while when you
use a soft robot you can deal with more
uncertain environments unknown object
can be touch it without damaging them if
you look at soft robots maybe your
zirconia is an animal or a be logical
structure using soft materials to build
your robot is something that is
completely new so a completely
revolutionary framework should be
developed the most paradigmatic probably
animal that could be an inspiration for
soft robots is the octopus because the
octopus completely lacks from any kind
of rigid part any bones from izybelle
roboticist this is amazing because you
see a completely soft a mold and you see
what is able to do and you want to do it
as well so at the very beginning of the
project we were sure it would have been
very crazy I mean no solutions were
available at the time what we did was to
translate what we understood from the
arm into an artificial platform the idea
was to replicate the main features and
bundle muscles that they have and here
you can see there are three cables so
that if one of them is pulled what this
obtained is a shortening of the arm of
course with a card if you pull all the
cables together you have only a
shortening without any kind of Bend the
octopus arm has been designed to work in
water so the best way to see the
performances of the arm is to see it
operating underwater
so the first thing when we saw that the
arm inside water we were amazed by the
fact that the motion
is so smooth and the behavior of the
prototype that is much closer to the
natural counterpart in fact by putting
an object that is very close to the
surface of the arm it automatically
adapt to the position of the object this
ability of motion American Airy and of
being able to exert forces it's also
interesting in the medical field in
particular in robotic surgery we share
the inspiration with the octopus project
because we are actually inspired by the
octopus tentacle we want to perform a
minimally invasive surgical procedure
with that arm this is a part of the
tentacle where you can see all the
functionality and especially the fact
it's really squeezable and soft but if
we take out the hair then the section
it's stiffer and it cannot be easily
deformed anymore and now we see a
manipulator which is made up of two
segments which can steel in all the
direction and also elongate this is a
standard training box for training
sergeant sergeant try these this system
and they actually perform a surgical
operation using a the view from the soft
robot I actually see surgeons really
happy to have the possibility to see
some surgical targets from that point of
view because with the rigid instruments
they couldn't reach certain point so
maybe one day we'll be really employed
in in a surgical operation but there's
still a lot of challenge to be to be
faced before
actually dim what I see for the future I
would pioneer is the fusion of soft
robots with traditional robots I don't
see a challenge between them but
cooperation we see a robot let's say
near everyone in the future I would like
to have a robot I mean close to me
you